on 9 11 people said here's our
opportunity
to help even though we knew nobody by
name we didn't they were all strangers
when they came to gander out of
community came together it was an
amazing feat
in the moments after the september 11th
terrorist attacks united states airspace
was closed
hundreds of inbound flights needed a
safe place to land one of those places
was gander newfoundland
once you get athletes across the ocean
the closest airport is gander and at
that day they were told to land at the
nearest airport and 38 aircraft was
nearer to gander than they were any
other airport
i get this call
get up in back of the airport so i'll go
up there
and i'm just in awe
i watch this big jet come in and i look
again and there's lights of another one
oh
god
the night the planes landed here i was
at the legion
and the first thing come out of my mouth
was
thank god they're coming here because i
know they're going to be looked after
not saying they wouldn't be looked after
elsewhere but i knew they would be
looked after here nearly 7 000 shaken
and disoriented passengers arrived in
gander almost doubling the population of
the tiny canadian town a plan of action
went into place just like that that's
what the whole community became involved
with
i don't know of anybody who who didn't
do something be it you know something
big or something small everybody seemed
to have done something because you knew
it had to be done all across gander
people opened their doors to stranded
passengers including over 700 at a local
primary school teachers went home that
day and emptied out their linen closet
took every blanket and pillow that was
not on the bed
and they brought it back to the school
by the early morning maybe five or six
o'clock
we had had four flights arrive at gander
academy
we kind of went on adrenaline i know i
didn't go home and sleep until 72 hours
later it just went on for days and
everything that we needed
seemed to come and i still don't know
how that happened
this is one from a school teacher in
montclair new jersey he sent me that on
the first anniversary
people invited them into their homes
gave the keys to their cars the keys to
their home and never blinked twice about
it the generosity of the people of
gander was a bright spot on one of the
world's darkest days when it was all
over i was never more prouder that the
greatest strength we have is our people
and we have greek people here in gander
you